hey there I'm Emily and I have little to
no chill I want to be more relaxed in
calm person so today I'm going to be
trying out three different meditations
that focus on the breath the body and
the soul and the real kicker is y'all
are doing this with me the coolest thing
about these meditations is that they can
be done anywhere your home your office
or the great outdoors so wherever you
are or whatever you're doing you're
ready to meditate 470 breathing is a
really great technique if you need to
calm down quickly it's basically a
natural tranquilizer for your nervous
system I'll explain the steps first and
then we'll practice it together so we're
gonna inhale through our nose for four
counts hold our breath for seven counts
and then exhale through our mouth and
through our tongue for eight counts you
ready let's do this inhale 2 3 4 hold 2
3 4 5 6 7
exhale 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 inhale 2 3 4 hold 2
3 4 5 6 7
exhale 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 inhale 2 3 4 hold 2
3 4 5 6 7
exhale 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 inhale 2 3 4 hold 2
3 4 5 6 7
exhale 2
three four five six seven eight first
meditation done what's gone to our
second meditation the body scan body
scans are super common way to meditate
the point is to try to concentrate your
mind and breath on your different body
parts I'm going to do mine line down but
you can practice your a sitting or in a
comfortable position begin by drawing
your attention inward gently close your
eyes take a deep breath in and a deep
breath out take notice of your feet and
calves clench the muscles if you want
feeling the tension
and release allowing your body to relax
and soften further put your attention on
your thighs and your butt clenching and
contracting the muscles take notice of
what this feels like
and release allowing your muscles to
soften contract the muscles in your
lower back and stomach area only do
what's comfortable and then when you're
ready release allow your stomach to
soften and your lower back to sink
further into the floor or your chair
tighten your chest and upper back
recognize the tenseness you have in this
area and release allow your upper back
to sink down relaxing further now
contract your arms and hands clenching
your fists tensing your muscles and
release scrunch your face and your neck
only do it's comfortable feeling the
tightness in your face now release take
a deep breath in and out bring your mind
into your body and feel yourself in this
present moment and when you're ready
open your eyes
congratulations we just did our second
meditation close your eyes and take a
few deep breaths this is the heart
chakra meditation we're going to take
some seriously delicious good love and
energy fill ourselves with it and then
release that to the world as you inhale
draw in energy and light as you exhale
release tension and negativity bring
your focus to your chest where your
heart chakra is located try to fill your
heart as it beats within your body
breathe in kindness and breathe out love
and gratitude
bring to mind someone who has shown you
kindness in Buddhist meditations this
person is often your mother but it
doesn't have to be think of this
generous and unconditional love that
this person has for you visualize this
person sending them feelings of love and
gratitude in the form of golden light
emerging from your heart chakra let the
light wrap around them like a stream of
water
now visualize someone you see often but
you don't know personally it could be a
barista at your favorite coffee shop
someone that does some small kindness
for you every day visualize this person
and send them feelings of love and
gratitude wrap them in warm beautiful
golden light now bring to mind someone
you don't particularly like allow
yourself to believe that any negative
actions taken against you were motivated
by their own difficulties empathize with
their struggles imagine the feelings of
happiness they would have if all their
suffering was released now visualize
yourself among your infinite peers who
long for peace just as you do wrap them
in your golden light imagine the golden
light emerging from your heart chakra
and embrace them all
congratulations we did it three
meditations done hey guys I hope you
enjoyed the video let me know your
favorite meditation is in the comments
below